I just know you from the the crypto
world and you what your yeah you're
famous on Twitter now right you've you I
think people have shown my my
progression in the five I'm between four
and five I think four is where your
believer five is where you're just nutso
evangelist where you you know you're
pounding the table every day you're an
official Bitcoin I think I'm about four
and a half I I'll tell you what Trump
said I both I think I could explain it
to him where he'd understand Bitcoin
then totally change his mind but what he
said about Facebook I tend to agree with
they are creating something a bank would
create they keep the float it's based on
the dollar there's nothing crypto about
it so I'm glad he doesn't like Libra I
just wish he understood Bitcoin yeah
look the best parallel I can come up
with this is Napster right when you
think of file-sharing back you know
twenty twenty-five years ago which was a
lot of people didn't like it but it was
easy to shut down and that there was a
company behind it right there was a CEO
to go and put pressure on that's very
similar to what Lieber is experiencing
now all right there's Facebook to go
after there's other corporations that
are participating that you can pressure
and regulate with Bitcoin there is no
CEO there is no headquarters you can't
send a letter or call somebody in for a
hearing and so I think that the
completely decentralized nature of the
asset is what makes it so compelling to
people and we're seeing that kind of
play out right now and it's really
highlighting the beauty of Bitcoin I
mean think of the Winklevoss I mean
after that that movie it's like you guys
should just go away and keep your 50
million or whatever but they didn't and
Tyler's quote I read that I said this
that sums it up in his quote is that you
know you I read it or automaticall
framework here has nothing to do as
politicking to do with devaluing the
currency has nothing you know no one can
[ __ ] in Bitcoin be regulated how would
you regulate yes how is can there's two
components right you can regulate the
ownership so they could ban the outright
ownership of Bitcoin they could say that
it's illegal for what India's owner they
it's illegal for financial institutions
to support crypto companies so I kind of
cut off the dependency on the legacy
financial system you can't change the
monetary policy you can't change the
algorithm that governs the asset unless
you have over 51% of people agree to
change it that's just not going to
happen and so I think that what we're
seeing is Bitcoin itself has grown in
such a decentralized fashion that it's
just too big to fail at this point
I think policymakers are not going to
want to destroy it either or prevent
ownership of it either as they finally
understand that you could take the the
friction of transferring money to
whomever you can take it to zero like
Amazon took retail to zero you can pick
up you know how much how powerful that
would be to take that business unless
unless it puts the Western unions of the
world out of business right and it in it
causes job losses etc and then where do
you think the politicians are gonna see
on that these are the kind of things
that this is a kind of creative
destructive you know trying to stop the
the Machine the Industrial Age yesterday
was such a big day in that you get to
remember you know gold for example
there's a seven trillion dollar assets
been around for thousands of years
Bitcoin is 200 billion dollars it's been
around for ten and a half years and we
have the Federal Reserve Chairman
talking about their alternatives to each
other any of the president coming out
and acknowledging it right talking about
it if you had said ten and a half years
ago the president United States is gonna
be tweeting about magic internet money
we would have never ever envisioned that
day and so I think that what we're
seeing is a shift in what we trust do we
trust the humans or do we trust the
algorithm if the gut one point where it
had had a value where it was being used
for a bigger percentage of global
commerce and transactions you can only
have 21 million coins if I got that
right that's correct
what would how much would you need in
total market cap to satisfy the you know
to utilize this as a currency and what
would that put a bit an individual
Bitcoin out what kind of price is that
yeah you know if you if you look at the
different arguments that are out there
right if it's just gonna replace gold or
kind of be comparative it'll be about
seven trillion the global money supply
call it you need two hundred billion two
hundred billion now there's an argument
that because it is a disinflation or a
deflationary asset what ends up
happening is when you have US dollars
right what you're doing what you're done
is your incentive us to take your wealth
out of dollars and put in a store value
s its real estate or etc if all of a
sudden the core unit of account the
currency that we use is actually a
deflationary asset you no longer
incentivize to move those that wealth
out of the currency and you just leave
it there and
as we've seen across a lot of technology
companies uber Airbnb etc their market
expanding technologies right it's
actually opened up the market cap and if
that happens to money what we could see
is let's say that we go from an eighty
eighty five trillion dollar market cap
to 125 150 trillion dollar market cap
and it's stealing that market cap back
from real estate or etc your start
talking about you know Bitcoin being in
the eight nine ten million dollars a
coin that's not gonna happen tomorrow
right that's gonna happen over really
really long one of the rouses that it
there's but there's only twenty-one
million and you couldn't use it as
curtain why couldn't you slice each
Bitcoin into millions I mean you can
there's a lot of them I think there's
there's a certain amount it's called a
Kernan I want there to be any way that
Satoshi there is one right yeah so I'll
get you one the Melissa you don't what
what there's one one Bitcoin can be
broken down in a hundred million
Satoshi's right it's highly divisible
why couldn't you do that anyway Anthony
they're yelling at me I don't you know
they don't appreciate it back there I
don't we're waiting for your wallet
address to go up on Twitter so people
can see that's where it gets complicated
because I've never even used one of
those little things you stick in those a
bit card no you be what you USB USB
things everything I thought it was a
keychain bag I said look at this ugly
key I don't know what it is anyway
you